shake things up
so we had a dance party tonight that I
just came back from and I got out of the
shower and decided you know what today I
want to shake things up I want to dress
up a little bit so I put on a tie I put
on a vast to put on the shirt and aninha
there's Nina you know Nina was like oh
my god you're all dressed up i'm not
dressed up or I'm going to do and I
showed up with the event and everybody
was freaking out that I was all dressed
up and it just kind of shocked me that
people don't do enough different things
I feel like we're locked into a set
personality and a set of what like just
you don't do enough different stuff
right like that that is so different
than everybody freaks out out you're
stuck in a routine you're sucking the
same thing you wear the same thing you
do the same thing every day and that
makes life boring and that makes life
stale people asking me am i doing a
performance tonight is it a special
occasion is it is it an anniversary why
am I dressed up and I said it's just
because so do something today just
because shake it up a little bit